من دواعي سرور وزير الخارجية ظريف أن تكون
معك مرة أخرى ، من الجيد أن تعود ، فأنت تعلم أن
الكثير من الناس يعتقدون أن
الحكومة الإيرانية تحاول إثارة التوترات
في الخليج الفارسي من خلال اعتراض
الناقلات من خلال إشارة إلى أنها
يمكن أن تمنع التدفق بطرق مختلفة  من
النفط من مضيق هرمز ، كما
ترى ، نحن في الخليج الفارسي ، لدينا
1500 ميل من الخط الساحلي مع
الخليج الفارسي ، أعني أننا سيطرنا على
مضيق هرمز ، أعني أن هذه
المياه هي شريان الحياة لدينا ، لذا فإن
أمنها أمر بالغ الأهمية  أهمية بالنسبة
لإيران ولكن عبر التاريخ
، وفرت إيران الأمن في هذه
المياه ، وتتدخل الولايات المتحدة
من أجل جعل هذه المياه غير آمنة
بالنسبة لإيران ، لا يمكنك جعل هذه المياه
غير آمنة لدولة ما وآمنة
للآخرين ، هل تعتقد أنه
نتيجة لهذا الشخص  هو إلقاء اللوم على
أنه يمكن أن يكون هناك تصعيد من شأنه أن
يؤدي إلى وقوع حادث عسكري جيدًا في
مثل هذا الجسم الصغير من المياه إذا كان لديك
الكثير من السفن الأجنبية ، فأنت
أعني  ستحدث الحوادث
كما تتذكر عام 1988 عندما أسقطت سفينة حربية أمريكية
في الحصن طائرة ركاب إيرانية مدنية
مما أسفر عن مقتل 290 راكبًا ، لذا فإن
الحوادث حتى الكوارث يمكن أن تحدث في
ظل هذه الظروف ، هل تعتقد
ذلك ولكن التوترات عالية كما
هي هناك إمكانية للحرب بشكل جيد
لا يمكنك ببساطة تجاهل
احتمالية وقوع كارثة ، لكننا جميعًا
بحاجة إلى العمل من أجل تجنب
وقوع حرب ، هناك حرب مستمرة الآن ، إنها
حرب اقتصادية ، وحرب اقتصادية ضد
إيران تستهدف السكان المدنيين ،
والرئيس ترامب
يقول رسميًا إنه  لا تشارك في
حرب عسكرية ولكن في
حرب اقتصادية لا ينبغي أن نفخر بالحرب الاقتصادية
لأنه في المواجهة العسكرية
قد يصبح المدنيون أضرارًا جانبية
بينما يكون المدنيون في الحرب الاقتصادية
هم الأهداف الأساسية ، فهل
فوجئت بقدرة الولايات المتحدة
إدارة ترامب لمنعك بشكل أساسي
من الانخراط في أي
نشاط اقتصادي دولي
حتى من بيع نفطك  في الأسواق الدولية ،
هناك دولة واحدة ، ومن
المؤسف ليس فقط لإيران ولكن بالنسبة
للمجتمع الدولي أن
الولايات المتحدة تستطيع في الواقع أن تتنمر على
اللاعبين المهمين في
الأسواق الدولية لإطاعة قواعدها ضد كل من
القانون الدولي وضد مصالحهم الخاصة ،
فمن المؤسف بالتأكيد أننا
ستستمر في بيع نفطنا الذي
ستجده ، لكن إنتاجك انخفض كثيرًا ، لقد
تم ذلك كثيرًا ولكننا سنجد طرقًا
لإصلاح الوضع كما رأيت أن
سوق العملات لدينا قد استقر الآن
بعد عام من التقلبات وهو ما
يعني
أنه يتحسن  هذا يعني أننا
سنستمر في مواجهة هذه الصعوبات
بكل فخر وبحصافة ،
هناك الكثير من الناس الذين يعتقدون
أن المشنوق حول عنقك
قد جعلتك الولايات المتحدة في
وضع تراجع فيه الاقتصاد ،
ويقول صندوق النقد الدولي إنه تقلص.  بنسبة خمسة وخمسة أو ستة في
المائة ، انخفضت العملة
بنسبة 50 أو 60 في المائة ، هل أنت محاصر ،
لا أعتقد أن الولايات المتحدة قد
وجدتها  ضروري بسبب أخطائه
في التركيز المفرط على قدرته
الاقتصادية
لتسليح الدولار الأمريكي وكما يخبرك أي محللين
على المدى المتوسط والطويل ، فم
المؤكد أن هذا سيكون له تأثير سلبي عل
هيمنة الدولار الأمريكي في ال
قتصاد العالمي  ترى الآن أن العديد من
الدول ، بما في ذلك حلفاء الولايات المتحدة ،
تبتعد عن الدولار باستخدام
عملاتها الوطنية العام الماضي ،
استخدمت إيران وتركيا عملاتهما الوطنية في
35 في المائة من تجارتها ، والبعض الآخر
يفعل نفس الشيء الذي قررت الصين وروسيا
وضع الدولار فيه جانبًا.  في
مساعهم الثنائية ، لديك الآن
سوق نفط بغير الدولار في
شنغهاي ، هذه حقائق اليوم
بسبب الاستخدام
المفرط للدولارات وتسليحها في
نهاية اليوم بسبب يأسنا
من هذا الهوس بإيران.
يريدون تدمير إرث شخص آخر
ووضع هذه الصفقة النووية التي تم
التفاوض عليها جانبًا والتي يستخدمونها بإفراط في استخدام
دولار القوة  وفي نهاية
اليوم ، ستكلفك التكلفة ، هل تعتقد أنك
ستكون قادرًا على بيع النفط إلى الصين
والهند في الأشهر القليلة المقبلة ،
سنواصل بيع النفط لمن وكيف
سيكون سراً من أسرار الدولة لأنه
بخلاف ذلك الولايات المتحدة  سيذهب ويمنعنا من
القيام بذلك ، لكننا سنستمر في بيع
الحمض النووي للنفط ، لا يمكن لأسواق النفط الدولية أن
تستمر دون أن يقيد وزيرنا بومبيو
حركتك بإحكام وفي
الواقع حركة موظفي السفارة الإيرانية
حتى أنه يقول إنه لا يريد
إعطاء منصة  للشباب ليطلقوا الدعاية الإيرانية ،
فلماذا لا يحصل على
فرصة للتحدث على التلفزيون الإيراني ، هل
ستقولون هنا أن وزير الخارجية
بومبيو يمكنه الظهور على التلفزيون الإيراني أولاً وقبل كل شيء
أنا ممتن لكم لمجيئكم إلى
مقر إقامتنا للقيام بذلك  مقابلة بدلاً
من مجيئي إلى الاستوديو الخاص بك وهذا
عبء عليك
وليس علي أنا سعيد جدًا لوجودي هنا
معك أعتقد أن القيود التي تم فرضها
على موظفينا ليست علي تذكر
أنني أتيت إلى هنا لبضعة أيام ثلاثة
بناء  عادة ما يكون ما أقوم به
هنا مهمتنا والأمم المتحدة.
ليس لدي أي عمل آخر هنا في
نيويورك. لا آتي إلى هنا
لمشاهدة معالم المدينة ، لقد قمت بمشاهدة معالم المدينة بشكل كافٍ
خلال أيام دراستي هنا في
الولايات المتحدة  لذلك لا أحتاج إلى القيام
بمشاهدة المعالم السياحية ولكن القيود
التي فرضوها على موظفي بعثتنا
غير إنسانية لا يمكن لأطفالهم الذهاب إلى
المدرسة ،
فهذه غير مقبولة لأنهم
مقيدون في حي دبلوماسي
للمقيمين ، نعم هذا لم يسمع به هؤلاء
ضد
وافقت الولايات المتحدة على عقد اتفاق
المقر لشرف استضافة مقر الأمم المتحدة ،
وهو يأتي مصحوبًا ببعض الالتزامات مع بعض
الطلبات ، ولكن بقدر ما
يدين الوزير بومبي بالظهور على
التلفزيون الإيراني ، فقد
رفض طلبات إجراء مقابلات من قبل
الصحفيين الإيرانيين و  أنا متأكد من أنه
سيجد طلبات كافية منه من
التلفزيون الإيراني من وسائل الإعلام الإيرانية الأخرى
وإذا قرر قبولها بنفس
الشروط التي أوافق عليها.  أقبل الظهور في
وسائل الإعلام الأمريكية ، أنا متأكد من أنه سيحصل على
فرصة يقول وزير الخارجية ظريف دونالد
ترامب إنه لا يريد حربًا مع
إيران ، كما قال مؤخرًا إنه
لا يريد تغيير النظام ، هل
تصدقه أعتقد أنه لا يريد ذلك.  لا أريد الحرب مع
إيران ، أعتقد أنه لا يهتم بمن
يحكم إيران
، ولا يريد تغيير النظام ، لكن هذا
ليس ما يهتم به الناس من حوله
وأعتقد أنه من المهم
أن ينظر الرئيس إلى الأشخاص من
حوله.  نتعامل معه في كلمته
بأنه لا يريد المزيد لا يريده
لا يريد تغيير النظام ولكن يمكنني أن
أؤكد له أن هناك عددًا قليلاً من الأشخاص
حوله يسجلون
أنهم يريدون الحرب والنظام.  التغيير
قيل لي أن الرئيس ترامب أرسل
رسالة إلى المرشد الأعلى لإيران
عرض فيها بشكل أساسي
استئناف المفاوضات بشكل جيد.
بحرص  المشكلة هي
أننا لا نستطيع البدء في التفاوض مع كل
إدارة أمريكية جديدة ، أي دولة
سوف تتعامل مع دولة أخرى بناءً
على حقيقة أن الحكومات تمثل
بلدانها ، كان ذلك يعني أننا أجرينا
للتو انتخابات هنا في الولايات
المتحدة ، ولم يكن لدينا ثورة.
لم يكن لدينا ثورة هنا في الرئيس الأمريكي ،
خلف ترامب
إدارة الرئيس أوباما لديها
اتفاقيات تنفيذية لديها معاهدات ،
لكن لديها جميع أنواع الاتفاقيات
التي لا تزال ملزمة
للبلد ، لا يمكنك ببساطة القول إنني لا
أحب الإدارة السابقة و
أرغب في إعادة التفاوض بشأن كل ما
فعلوه وقد يكون ذلك مشكلة داخلية بالنسبة لك ،
لكن بالنسبة لنا قضينا عدة سنوات ساعات
وأيام وشهور ليالي إحدى
جلسات التفاوض التي أجريناها مع
السكرتير كيري بدأت في الساعة التاسعة
مساءً وانتهت بدون  وقفة
في الساعة 6:00 من صباح اليوم التالي ، هذا
ليس شيئًا لإعادة التفاوض الآن إذا قال
الرئيس ترامب أن هذا ليس
هذا لم يكن  معاهدة كانت هذه مجرد
اتفاقية تنفيذية ، فهذه قضايا محلية ،
لكنه انتهك عددًا كافيًا من
المعاهدات ، تذكر معاهدة INF ، تذكر NAFTA ،
تذكر اليونسكو ،
لكن اسمحوا لي أن أقترح فوزًا للجميع ،
لقد قلت إنه يجب أن يكون هناك ربح
للجميع nigga  عليه أن يربح شيئًا
أيضًا وسيكون الفوز هو موافقتك
على العودة إلى طاولة المفاوضات ،
وهناك تعليق لهذه الدراسة الجديدة التي
تفرض عقوبات على الولايات المتحدة  توقف أثناء
الحديث لكنك توافق على الحديث عن
صفقة الصواريخ الباليستية النووية
وأنشطة إيران الإقليمية جيدًا أولاً وقبل
كل شيء لم نغادر طاولة المفاوضات ،
نحن في المفاوضات ،
غادرت الولايات المتحدة طاولة المفاوضات ،
لذا إذا وضعوا العقوبات جانبًا ، يمكنهم ذلك.
أعود إلى طاولة المفاوضات
ويمكنهم البدء في المناقشة معنا على
طاولة المفاوضات ، لقد ناقشنا دائمًا
القضية النووية حول كيفية
تنفيذ الاتفاقية التي لدينا ،
لذلك نرحب أكثر بالقيام بذلك بشأن
الصواريخ والقضايا الإقليمية التي لم
نشهدها.  جدية الولايات
المتحدة في تنفيذ ما اتفقوا عليه بالفعل ،
علينا أن نرى
جدية الولايات المتحدة ، فنحن لن
نتفاوض بشأن دفاعنا ، إنه
ارتباط عاطفي تاريخي
لشعبنا الذي مر به شعبنا في
حرب ثماني سنوات عندما كانوا  استُهدفوا
عندما تم تمطرهم
بالصواريخ والقنابل وحتى
الأسلحة الكيميائية ولم يعطنا أحد الحد الأدنى من المعلومات
كل شخص من
السوفييت آنذاك الذين قدموا طائرات عملاقة
للعراقيين للأمريكيين الذين أعطوهم
صندوقًا مربعًا للاستطلاع للفرنسيين
الذين أعطوهم صواريخ Exocet
للبريطانيين الذين أعطوهم زعماء
الدبابات للألمان الذين أعطوهم
أسلحة كيميائية للجميع
لم يساعدنا أحد حتى في السماح لنا بشراء صاروخ واحد
للدفاع عن أنفسنا ، لذلك من
المستحيل إخبار الشعب الإيراني
لماذا تبيع الولايات المتحدة ما
قيمته سبعة وثمانين مليار دولار من
المعدات العسكرية لتجنب أن تشتري المملكة العربية السعودية ما
قيمته سبعة وثمانين مليار
دولار من المعدات العسكرية و
تبيع الولايات المتحدة ما يزيد عن خمسين
مليار دولار من
المعدات العسكرية لمنطقتنا إلى الخليج الفارسي
العام الذي يتوقعون منا أن نتخلى عنه وسيلتنا
الوحيدة والأكثر أهمية للدفاع ،
لذا دعني أسألك قليلاً ليس لدينا
الكثير من الوقت  هو
الرئيس ترامب الذي تقول أنه يجب أن يكون
السبيل الوحيد للخروج من
هذا هو الفوز وليس الخسارة كيف
هل تمنح الرئيس ترامب فوزًا جيدًا
يمكن للرئيس ترامب في الواقع أن يجد
آلية لتحقيق السلام
والأمن الدوليين من خلال الاتفاق من
خلال التفاهم بدلاً من
المواجهة ، فقد اتخذ قرارًا حكيماً للغاية
بعدم بدء حرب من خلال اتخاذ قرار
بعدم مهاجمة إيران انتقاميًا
لأنه  كان يعلم أنه كان
سيستجيب ، ثم كما قلت ، يمكنك
بدء الحرب ولكن لا يمكنك إنهاؤها ، لذا
كان هذا قرارًا حكيماً للغاية
ويمكنه أن ينسب الفضل
إليه لاستعادة معاهدة جيدة جعلت
كلاً من إيران و  الولايات المتحدة
وبقية العالم أكثر أمانًا ، يمكننا أيضًا أن
ننسب الفضل إلى حقيقة أنه كان
قادرًا على التأكد
من الالتزام بالاتفاقيات الدولية ، لذا فهذه
كلها انتصارات مهمة للرئيس
روه وللولايات المتحدة وأنا متأكد
سيكون هذا إرثًا مهمًا للغاية
بالنسبة له ، لكن يبدو
أنه ستكون هناك حرب باردة طويلة في الوقت الحالي
، لقد تعرضنا لضغوط
من الولايات المتحدة لمدة 40 عامًا.  سنوات
ليست جديدة بالنسبة لنا لقد تعلمنا حماية
مصالحنا لحماية شعبنا على
الرغم من ذلك ، لكنك الولايات المتحدة
التي تراها منعتنا من الحصول على
وسائل الدفاع التي بنيناها بأنفسنا ، لقد
منعونا من الحصول على الوقود من أجلنا.
نحن  أنشأنا مفاعلًا نوويًا
أنتجنا الوقود بأنفسنا ، فهم
يمنعوننا من جني الأموال التي نحتاجها من
خلال بيع نفطنا لإطعام
سكاننا لشراء دواء
لخشخاشنا ،
وسنجد طرقًا للتحايل عليه ،
ولا ينبغي لهم القدوم والشكوى بعد ذلك
أعتقد أن هذه ليست
تفضيلاتنا ، فالشعب الإيراني يفضل
المشاركة ولكن إذا أرادت الولايات المتحدة
منعنا من المشاركة ،
فلن نقبل ببساطة إما الخضوع
لإرادة قوة أجنبية أو
ببساطة السماح لشعبنا بالمعاناة.
سيجدون طرقًا للالتفاف حوله ويجب على الولايات
المتحدة قبول العواقب